hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast style very interesting
people what went wrong and the
prediction of functional effects and the
zoning variation presented by dr. Jana
Ballmer
associate professor department of
biochemistry and microbiology at Rutgers
University community builders and all
the years and uproots moderators which
measurement we're trying to bring you
this educational virtual conference
presented by labyrinth for meeting 2050
social networks website provider a
virtual events webinars and complain to
these collaborations among the Islamic
recitation will work today
we want to hear from you questions
comments and even cancers to be
submitted here between Q&A button at the
lower left of your screen we're trying
to get to everyone
if not we'll make sure to follow up with
you by email you can also enlarge this
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
your slides window you can appear or see
the presentation offer let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button at your
lower back this is this educational
webinar SMS offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
it over please click on the CC button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage consol the process for
obtaining your credits and now like to
introduce our speaker for today dr. Jana
longer welcome
hi everybody thank you so much for the
introduction Susie so students we're
going to talk about variants in exomes
of humans actually so not all they're
into created equal as the title of this
talk but if I was a little bit less
formal and finding the title for the
self I would actually say well we've
been doing it all wrong and I've been in
the field for a while trying to evaluate
the effects of genomic variation and I
can tell you for sure we've been doing
this all wrong
so let me start with what if considers
the holy grail of genetics and genomics
and I think that the idea here is that
we want to predict for disposition to
disease so I like to cite my favorite
book it's a russian book called master
and amar very nervous and it has been
translated to quite a few languages so
if you're out there looking for
something to read is really excellent
starts out this particular passage was a
conversation between a regular human
being and the devil and the devil is
interested in this human being and says
what are you going to die and the guy
goes well nobody knows and it's nobody's
concerned and one of the devil servant
says sure nobody knows kind of
surpassing there he'll die in nine
months next February of liver cancer in
the clinical first Moscow State
University Ward number four and they
think that for the past 15 years of 1 in
15 years since the first genome has been
sequence we've been trying to use the
genomic information in order to make
these kinds of predictions what is the
disease that you're predisposed to how
much time do you have before you develop
it and of course how can you avoid it so
a lot of methods have been built in
order to evaluate the effects of genomic
variation and this is just some of them
life has been tuned with is stolen from
human Brenner
from one of his conferences and what you
see is the 2016 flight and probably
since then the number of methods that
were available have actually grown
tremendously but what you see here is
the message that most people
you know all of these methods try to
predict functional sets of variants and
excite variants I usually mean single
nucleotide polymorphism single
nucleotide variants of any frequency
that are also not synonymous which which
really means just a very small set of
variants in the essence that changed the
resulting protein sequence now the slide
is a lot more information than just the
names of these predictors also have some
level of estimate of how often these
predictors are used based on how often
their status and some of them older
predictors who here are sift and
polyphen
and of course most people know what
those are but also my own favorite
method snap and mutation taster and the
asian of that are actually on here as
well okay so what are these method to do
as I said they make predictions of
variants and they do this from the basis
of the various features that are
specific to particular proteins and what
we did for now Eastern paper that we
published is the sort of arrange some of
the most common variant effect predictor
according to the number of features that
they use it in for this protein features
variant features and insert in order to
make the prediction and I think on the
left like sift which only uses
evolutionary information to hold that
which only use a structural information
use a limited set of features and also a
limited set of algorithmic evaluations
and comparative methods more to the
right where we start accumulating
features and using more complicated
algorithms such as machine learning for
instance and then eventually we get to
these methods which are meta methods so
predictive and medicine which which
actually are these as influence on the
output of other methods and all of these
methods are in use today and all these
methods have their own suppose they're
like these are people who like
soundness is better
another so what we wanted to know is how
well in fact the lead method suit and as
we found in evaluating this was a very
curious thing so there were explicitly
two types of methods to lose that we're
trying to evaluate the effectiveness by
a physical matter so what is this type
of structure that's in a more of
molecular biology manner so what is a
second function and what is a
possibility association and what we
found is that some of the methods that
are a that particular part so let's say
biophysics method seems to perform
similarly so this is an example cut
music is a Memphis trying to predict an
open temperature and what you're looking
at is this experimental evaluations of
these variants in the y-axis and the
predictions on the x-axis and we're
seeing is that there is actually a
really decent correlation our 0.61
between the predictions in the reality
so that last okay what is another method
of something similar and we found that
there is a necessary to predict free
energy of folding of proteins and
methods called sapphic and this is also
a recent methods and guess for the
correlation of the prediction and the
experimental data is about are from 0.65
naturally went back so messes us a
little older and this method is also
holding energy method and this is a
Newton's and I need to have an hour of
your 171 so you can argue the 0.71 is
slightly better than 0.6 one or you
could say that this is within standard
error but you could see that these
methods to form roughly similarly about
the same range and depending on basis
has a few spoons to meet for making this
evaluation you could almost take that
they're identical although they do use
very different features in order to make
those predictions now this is true not
only of biophysics methods so there are
methods does predict molecular functions
of such an entity so for instance there
is one is actually a very interesting
one because of structure base
and every disclaimer in one of the
courses an online but management
critical sections and function and the
idea is that every publication of a new
method has to somehow comparing
themselves to and all the methods and
one way of doing it is by looking at the
ROC curve there here operating curve
wickety is this one to be a fart I out
in this curve around the true positive
rate axis as you possibly can so the
idea was this particular graph is that
mod outperform snap which is the method
that I developed a while back and this
which is one of the most commonly used
methods and also without reforms
polygons the original Politan right here
which is also class so you can't really
draw curve for either cysts or sisters
are here or propolis and the reason is
because they have default cut-offs for
calling something effect or no effect
but again the main message here is that
mod outperforms other methods now when
you go further and look at let's say
probiem and you also have a very similar
curve and again in firmly and actually
they manage to get this curve by varying
the output and this thing is over here
the drinker here but overall probiem
seems to be doing fairly well with the
area under the curve a point a story and
actually about as well or better than
other methods out there and then of
course you probably get into trends here
you go to solid time to Impala console
is this green line over here and falling
on to that significantly better than all
the methods compared to of course I know
exception so when we released the second
version of snap and asked to we said
actually well snap to in doing much
better than anybody else so here this is
our method and by the way this is our
old methods in light blue and we're
doing actually better than polygon which
is in this orange thing here so every
method to be published has to somehow
show with utility and we do for our beef
who better than somebody else but the
question is that what is why are we
still not up there in terms of
performances where consistently doing
better than somebody else well let's put
this question and I heard before was oh
I'm sorry
and here's the the method that is a meta
meta taking into account snap and other
inputs so like Polly Simon system what
we show here is a Messersmith is also
doing better than everybody else's this
line over here okay so why are we not
getting some hundred percent performance
and some one of the questions was really
your men during the wrong thing so this
to positive rate versus false positive
rate is probably not the best way to
measure and there was a publication we
complete from all opinions lab that had
introduced this other measure of
performance for these methods and here
you actually looked at six different
things so you could move that mathius
correlation coefficient of specificity
as positive and negative predictive
values and the man what you wanted to do
is maximize the volume volume of this
cube which would give you an estimate of
how well a particular method performs in
all of these categories and in this
particular scenario not surprisingly
Ponty two which is the methods of the
spacer was about actually does better
than everybody else maximizing the cube
Logan but in the end you could see that
the cube volume is actually not that
much bigger than the first method
developed for this particular type of
prediction which is this okay so why
some methods that are meant to predict
the concise perform similarly right so
all of these methods try to predict
effect confidence by physical effects
Humphreys is going to a functional
effect contradicts misogynistic young
males performed similarly well the
reason the primary reason for this is
that evolutionary conservation follow
these methods is was bigger than the
feature as we're all going to does well
because flip switch is only based on
evolution
conservation performs really well and
you know it performs really well because
used as a baseline comparison in almost
every publication the second reason is
because these assess that are used for
training and testing these methods are
the same even though the authors have
these hosts the prediction outcomes will
be different which is very strange
phenomenon to me but it does work this
assumption works somehow broadly because
there is a really significant
correlation between the three questions
of interest in this field and
specifically the correlations are
between whether the variance has an
impact on molecular function of
structure whether it has an impact on
epigenetics is what is correlated with
disease and whether a variant has
evolutionary fitness which is not how
better and here is what happens then the
assumption is that let's say business is
actually the leader that's a fair
assumption if the organism is very fit
it's probably not least but then we look
at the distribution of conservation
scores which are representative of
business somehow versus of the variance
tests which are either disease and
that's omen variance online mendelian
and men disease variance Mendelian
diseases and khansamar which are disease
associated variants versus the 1000
genome data and mutation across all
possible means of growth over the
dissolution of genome and what you see
is that disease areas are in fact most
frequently distributed in this higher
concentration I guess you see the error
here anyway I just hired conservation
region of the graph so these are green
line variant envies the red lines areas
which are the B's variants are
concentrated on the right however there
are two things to note here one is that
even though the variants disease
variants are concentrated on the right
there is also a significant fraction of
them on the left side right so the idea
that you have to be concerned in order
to be disease is actually not true so
sickness is not equal
and one over what you see is that there
is a significant number of variants that
are on the right which are conserved but
they're not disease so actually the 1000
Genomes data which which contains
variants from healthy individuals are
also on in the physicians which are
normally conserved so we establish this
sickness does not necessarily equal
disease okay
what about other things what the
structure is
we'll discuss changing structures will
getting disease and we know the disease
variants frequently destabilize this is
from a surveillance by paper from John
wall's group and what you're seeing is
these two arrows as we sees around
arrows on the screen indicates of
thoughts like spikes of where variants
change the stability of the protein and
we're looking at disease very so you see
this a very large fraction of these
variants of our actually stability
changes so in one sense you can say this
changing structure in equal to disease
but if you can imagine this is not
always the case rate as you can see this
is not all of the cases now the red
arrow is pointing to the slice which is
not a zero slice where there is no
effect on structure and therefore we
cannot say that changes in structure
equal to disease that you have to have a
change in structure in order to have
disease and more importantly if you look
at knowledge these variants rate so this
is very healthy individuals you see that
the significant number of them also
change structure and that also
reinforces the story that structure is
not equal to disease and it sort of just
in the last exercise here this is the
variants that are sorted by their
flexibility whether they are flexible
and flexible and that's another
presentation of structure and we are
asking whether there is an effect on
function from you to be very intimate
we're seeing is this yes in fact the
variant effect function a frequently
inflexible and therefore are inflexible
positions of the protein and therefore
you can say
actually structure does inform function
very much and this does it does but you
could also see that there is lots of
variants that affects function that have
no effective structure and that also
makes sense but you cannot in fact
equate functional structure so this is a
very strong message that most people
don't understand or sweep under the rug
when building method so what does this
come out to when we're trying to
differentiate not anonymous Larry
intersect we're dealing with this sort
of a three-tiered Venn diagram an
insatiable observable variant where the
variants are actually causing functional
effects or have a fitness effects or are
associated with disease but these three
pieces of the Venn diagram do not have
to necessarily overlap so for instance
over here with your seeing is a bunch of
variants where there is no functional
effect but there is an effect of
business and really this is variants
where you would have changes increase in
quantity but not the function of
individual molecules so there is no
change to functions if you have more or
less of this function depending on the
quantity of the protein and on the other
hand you could have these variants over
here which are clearly disease variance
right and they may or may not be
functionally significant but they have
no effect on fitness and how can that be
and what really is the variance of cause
disease but in post reproductive age
which basically means that they have no
preferences so the time chain invariant
my effect actually requires establishing
what effect you are looking for but what
you have established what effect you are
looking for then question is how do we
separate no effect varies from effect
variance using some features do so in
this particular case you have one
specific features view but you can see
that you can do this in multiple in
multiple dimensions and what you were
certain here is that given this
particular feature scale you would not
be able to differentiate things that are
over here because they're the feature
score is the
save professional test settings and the
the problem here is that it's very
difficult to determine when something
has no effect so accessibility we all
know what effective so for instance if I
ask you are there in your red cars in
this world you could immediately tell
media there is red there are red cars
because I see at least one red car so if
that is really easy to entertain there
is an effect you now are there any
yellow cars in this world and let's say
yellow is the negative label of bread
right so are there any yellow cards in
one well I don't know let me check let
me extend my world and extend it some
more and extend it some more and in the
end I still don't know because I can
continue expanding this world and in
order to say that there are no yellow
cards in this world I actually have to
explore the entire world and this is a
lot harder to do the same the other red
card in the world when I see a red car
so access is much easier to ascertain
and notice so we come to this notion of
populism label training where we should
really be looking at methods developed
not as positive versus negative but a
positive versus unlabeled
where the unlabeled collection is some
distributions some distribution of
positive and negative and here it's
indicated by this yellow line so imagine
that these variants have no labels on
them but we know that the distribution
has this version of sectarian right so
in me and what it comes down to is
trying to figure out with these alpha
alpha is 1 minus output of the for the
probabilities of seeing effect and no
effect and actually this is fairly
difficult to do and it has been nearly
impossible to do off until fairly
recently
so my collaborator and his lab has
published
really interesting paper to do that
anomaly ham so hopefully we'll see the
development of new methods heat up but
let me just sort of say that this hasn't
happened yet so what are we dealing with
not the current tools use father's on
label training so what do they use they
use positives and negatives and most
commonly they use negative these non
neutral variants how to label their non
neutral well they both online mendelian
inheritance in man database and they say
well these are Mendelian disease causing
variant so they must be non neutral and
let me look at the ornithologist
sequences across different species and
they say okay well any change within the
same person performing the same function
of different species must be very much
different so what they do is the answers
they said this to be those are the
ovarian to be non neutral and they said
the orthology series to be neutral but
in reality what event of being is that
they say we're going to compare disease
to fitness and this is a problem and I
mentioned to you before okay well we
trained Smith when we trained our method
we also does not use positive unlabeled
training but we just like to make the
fact that using disease resistance is
not a good idea so what we did instead
is used for mentally determined
functional effects so rather than saying
that this has an effect because there is
a disease associated with it we said why
don't we say all available
experimentally determined functional
effects in the literature because again
I'm determining an effect is actually an
easier thing than determining no offense
now we still have to address the other
side the negative side and we have some
ways of doing this which included
looking at the solidus sequences but at
least we had one site that was somehow
figured out so just to sort of give you
back back ends here of snaps boring
because I'm going to talk about it for a
little bit so now is is a mess of centra
screen economics
more servants myself basically tries to
score all the neutral variances minus
100 and only non neutral ones of black
countries and of course not within Iran
that's our base methods we never get
minus 100 and 100 or very rarely gets
there so what happens is there is this
seal from zero range from zero snaps
score to 100 snaps for which is we
consider non neutral and then there is
the range in the other direction from
0-100 which were considered neutral so
when we look at the distribution of the
actual very precise predictions we get
something that is looking kind of like
this and let me just go through with
your team here the dark blue line is
where we're facing synonymous variance
so we remember looking at proteins not
the actual VMAs and so if we look at a
13 and we say there is an assignment
position 7 what would be the effect and
the protein function if we replace in
the firing position 7 by defining and
it's a silly question to ask because
you're replacing and finding by the
finding and you're not going to find
genetic level you are doing this on a
freaking level so really there is no
difference so this is kind of a safe
check of sanity check of how well the
method does is resisting effect the
variance and when you see again dark
blue is that there is the majority of
the variance are predicted correctly to
be neutral on the left side of 0 with
this curve right here however on the
right hand side the receives blue as
well some fraction I was here and those
are obviously prediction errors so this
is the limitation of our method we can't
do better than that
the other thing that you're seeing here
is these light blue variants which are
basically also as derived right so
remember I showed you this alignment of
orthologs of genes that are the same and
other species and we're saying let's
look for various different amino acids
in that gene and those were going to
call mutual now let me just sort of
immediately say that there have been a
lot of studies that show that proteins
and different organisms have different
levels of activity so something that
playing the hepatitis role in the yeast
is probably very different from the
hexatronic over the mouse however there
is also this estimate from partnership
and also the 2012 publication where we
say that about 10% of the variance and
infallible sequences are actually
usually compensated by other variants in
that same sequence which we by peoples
never considered so we know that this
variant is not usual because it requires
some other compensation in order to
perform celebrity performance and
function so that this is a PC the
ortholog and the other side over here is
the DMD severe variants of T and he
contributed database and what we're
looking at is these variants which are
known experimentally to be rather severe
knockout functional effects on function
so what what are we seeing
then the things to the right over here
in light blue those are the orthologs
that are impossible prediction errors
but as I told you they could just really
beat the or solidus variants which are
not neutral and looks like there's about
10% of them there so that would be in
line with was commercial convention and
then these things that we hear all the
prediction errors because it's very hard
to imagine that somebody finds severe
effects without actually having a reason
to find out those devices so so far so
good snap performed very well so we also
found something that was very unexpected
because we trained to map directed nice
minus 1 minus 100 versus 100 we didn't
really give it a value we're going to
say ok this is a little bit functionally
more important versus this is a lot more
function
quite important but we see that snot
learn across this training the recognize
that there is a difference between mild
severe and moderate effects and so this
is a severe effect that I was looking as
in last place this is the moderate
effect and this light color over here is
the mild effects and you see that
consistently the distribution over to
the level or more to neutrality so it is
much harder in other words for snaps to
recognize as nonmutual a variant that
has a mild attachment a variant has a
severe effect so just out of curiosity
and you can pause me for about two
seconds try to guess where the variants
that are annotated as neutral for
mentally neutral placed in this curve
okay hopefully you've tried and actually
the reality is this and if you recall
the the neutrals that we had originally
means synonymous neutrals and not
nihilism easy neutrals were actually
placing quite differently so between
this and this there is a huge difference
so actually what we're finding is that
variance that somebody says are neutral
are actually placing halfway on the
right non neutral and halfway on the
left and the reason for this is again
it's very hard to identify variants that
are that are really truly neutral and
there's really three things was that are
important here one reason for this kind
of an equivalency degree neutral is this
variance election is bias so this is an
example from a paper by collaborators of
ours as we investigated the pathogenic
role of the miscommunications found Anna
mortally obese cohort by comparing the
activity of a different mutation
accounted for receptors to that of the
wild-type receptor so basically what
they're doing is they're saying let's
say these obese individuals and looked
at their mill important for acceptors
find the variance that
are different from the healthy
individuals and evaluate how well no
variants do and they do a lot of
variance they find a lot of variance a
values a lot of bearings and the first
five panels of this figure I'm not
suggesting you look at it in detail but
the first five panels of the figure is
really that finding aspects in these
areas now the last panel is almost an
afterthought in the last panel when they
say yes there is most effect in the
other bearings but here's here's these
two variants really is gradient 11
varying and hardening 1815 which
actually have no effect
they bias the agonist which is the
y-axis here the same ways of the biotech
variances well the catch is that same
group actually then goes ahead a few
years later and doesn't evaluation of
gold leaf variance for another form of
activity of not going for receptor and
what they find is these two variances
that they were looking at initially
actually have an effect on constitutive
activity on a different activity of the
same receptor so if they have done the
work completely they wouldn't have
initially called these variants neutrals
and then the first thing final thing
here is the defect identification is
subjective so if we were looking at the
whole temporary facilities are in the
presence of valuable type versus other
variants so here we're looking at a
variance which would give us no effect
and here we're looking at a variance
less would be okay and the only
difference between these two is the
amount of the agonist that is necessary
for this functional activity so if you
measure things in the beginning on the
left and the lower concentrations then
you are doing the same a quiet place and
if you measure things on the right the
higher concentration and you're doing
worse than liable and of course those
two things are acquired so what that
brings up to is the basis has it been
valuated for for which we have effect
and we find that most of the variants
that are designated functionally neutral
should not move
with half of the variants that are
designated functionally neutral happen
to either disrupt structure or to
stabilize the protein or even once I
close disease and this this is not to
scale obviously but this actually means
that these neutral variants have not
been followed up have not been followed
up essentially the words of this bring
us let's let's get back to our map for
what we're finding is that these neutral
variants in blue distribution here is
actually 50% non neutral and it is
roughly 50% non neutral and 50% neutral
and actually if we consider another
database of variants which contain
allocate variances disease or non
disease so this is polymorphic variants
which do not post these as the reasons
but you see in a very funny fashion it
was as a disease variance distributed
very much like the severe functional
effect variance so that's great but also
the polymorphic variants are actually
distributing very much like the new
covariance and actually even more to the
right of the of the graph which suggests
they're more non neutral one so in fact
what we call polymorphism not
necessarily not having functional tests
so again let's backtrack to our methods
many methods use disease-bearing
versus varies in more columns for
development so in their head on is an
amino acid from our solid in sequence or
equation by an amino acid from an
arcology sequence and off in an often
disease helping Mendelian disease
variant however the reality is is the
their disease variants are not
necessarily I'm sorry the reality is
that the disease variants are very often
conserved and by definition there are
solidus variants are not conserved so
what we end up doing with a lot of these
funds computational methods is trying to
distinguish conserve versus not preserve
via a whole range of feature admission
nothing
conservation and we are very much
surprised when we don't do fairly well
with that and unfortunately this is not
representative of biology in biology
what we often have is not be toggled
switches where it's on or off but rather
this gradation of functionality you can
have more function or less function
depending on the variance you have now
of course this was this scheme would
take care of the error on the disease
site so basically these variants are
conserved so but they're fully
functional free and you they will take
care of the error in the neutrality
sentence you're seeing here is that
there is a large fraction of disease
variants which actually has to be found
and cuz it's announcing their positions
in these 1,000 positions where you put
things in and have a different
functionality so the function is still
there but it's just dialed down so in
the end but that's not what we see what
we observe is that there are really two
types of positions of current readings
one position is a table set of position
mastaba and the other set of positions
is reassessed in fuzzles there is the
change functions are very common they
basically knock it out and there's very
few variants that do not change function
and the real steps there is a budget
variance that are responsible for a
range of functionality so all varies
change functions but it's not a knocking
out of function so we have an
experimental basis kind of looks like
this so we're looking at the last one
regressor evaluation of functionality
and what you're seeing over here on the
left hand side where my error is is the
normal functionality of tyrosine in
position 47 and we see the y axis here
is the fold change in activity and when
it's the wild side there is no full
change and then what happens is you
start introducing Mary and you go to the
right here and what you're finding is
that in the best
scenario you get about a 30-fold change
and actually you know the other
scenarios you get all of these 10,000
full changes which basically mean an
opt-out of function so this is a very
clear toggle variance on the other hand
you have a position of valine position
number 52 over here in fact it's not on
the left should tell you something the
fact that you can go to the left and
then you can decrease some increased
functionality versus going to the right
when you can decrease functionality
suggest that this position is colourings
all kinds of substitutions we actually
change your function slightly so what we
did with these variants is we try to
make predictions with the existing
computational methods to see if we can
differentiate the two because clearly
they are supposed to be differentiated
and when we're seeing oh sorry so just
to sort of give you what we want to see
the optimal predictive model is if we
normalize the predicted score from zero
to one with anything about 0.5 being non
neutral so this way non neutral in this
way in neutral below 0.5 we should give
this distribution of various pores which
size of holders of this group so this is
a violent plot and the thickness of the
of the marker indicates how many
variants are there so basically for
neutral predictions was the expect is
that the variance will have no effect in
either possible Oriol set positions
because it can't be more or less neutral
you just have to be neutral right so no
matter what introducing variant to
introduce whether it's real class or not
or our toggle position if the effect is
neutral the distribution of scores
should be the same I'm also sending
another neutral world the sample
positions will not have function to your
segment to score much higher and the
recent positions will have a whole range
of functionality so you expected to
range across the entire spectrum so what
do you think the actual predictions look
like what we found was very
disappointing even though under
Hannibal so the first thing that they
found is that toggle neutrals are
incorrectly predicted as more non
neutral than Rio sub non neutrals this
is a mouthful there but what you're
seeing as these do a serious areas over
here also predicted less functionally
significant with these neutral variants
over here just because of the position
that they happen to be in and actually
if you look at the p-value over here
what you see is that for snap and
praveen the first two methods here these
p-values are not significant so you can
say the distributions are the same for
these reassessed non neutrals and model
neutral American chemist rescue and
Solomon to actually focus on neutrals
are predicted way up here which is very
much in line with non neutrality but
what you see is that this is actually a
significant difference between Mutual
and non neutral and the non neutral in
research positions score lower than the
neutral in table position so this is a
problem clearly second problem is that
recent neutrals and non neutral form
differentiate early so if we only focus
on the real stuff delicious and we say
okay we're not looking at me from their
positions let's just look at the ones
that are not conserved what we find is
that it's very hard to differentiate the
neutral from non neutral for everybody
and in fact for for must-read to there
is absolutely no differentiation the
others do better but still there is a
large fraction of non neutral variant
here here and here
which end up being below the zero below
the neutrality line so real second
children on neutral the poorly
differentiated and this is even better
when is the situation for now goes
because install those positions new
children are neutrals are not
differentiated at all so in this
particular scenario no method that you
see here that's a thing for for
differentiation between powerful
neutrals in the New Jersey says this is
not a potentially possible neutral
substitution in any of the trouble
position for any of the matter now of
course oh one more thing that is a
problem for us here is except if you
remember the neutral so you can't have
more or less neutrality and what we find
is actually that there is a huge
difference between neutrals that are in
double positions and non neutral and
neutral in real such positions and this
is also very strange because again
neutrality should not be graded okay so
what we do manage to predict the one
thing that we manage to predict is that
real sudden power among neutrals are
correctly differentiated so in fact the
real certain are neutrals them to have a
range where the toggle non neutrals them
to be more explicitly defined in all
methods and in fact you see that the
p-values further low for everybody and
actually most importantly what we see is
that realistic neutrals are correctly
differentiated from fowl non neutral and
in the training set so we train our
methods to differentiate essentially
these two things the toggle mal neutral
this severe back variance from the real
stuff neutral means basically or solidus
variations and we do fairly well all
method to do fairly well the T values
are very low at doing that particular
task
so just as a side note I'd like to point
out that method corn are only somewhat
correlated with the Restonic levels of
activity to legal apparently bad job
with real static levels of activity but
for task two which by the way was not
optimized unders and the only difference
that it has from everybody else is that
it uses experimental data but it's not
do we actually get a fairly high Pearson
R is in correlating the actual effects
with various status level solicitors
okay so what does this mean well if you
look at the whole genome scale what you
find is that for thousands of thousand
genomes area
this thing on the right is not for from
0 to 100 most many of the variance court
here so roughly half of the variance in
the human genome whether they're common
or rare or whatever and off on the right
side of 0 so they're not neutral and
what we also surprisingly find that the
common variants are more often non
neutral than their buns as indicated by
these curves so there's a usual standard
procedure of saying common variance must
be initial is actually not true but if
you think about this a little more what
you realize is that the common variants
are they have to be non neutral they
have to be either as on pages on their
way in or do it serious on the way out
and therefore they have to be non
neutral so this is not do these various
the success variances have a business
preference okay and so the sort of
around this office also means that a
little remove variance of large effect
from the population doesn't involve area
so here the 1000 Genomes base of the
healthy variants are represented in
black and white the red lines here are
variance in the set of Christians where
which are not possible with a mutation
with a single negated form or difference
and the blue line here is the most
possible mutation and what we see of
course the reassuringly is that variants
that are not an impossible standard
score higher so there are more
deleterious when you this but what is
more interesting here is that there is a
difference between what is the observed
snips and healthy individuals the 1000
Genomes data versus the expected random
snips in just sort of generate as they
just visited and what we find is that
this is actually in line with the
biochemical view of mutation so
basically you can say okay there is that
are here there biochemically website
from there physiologically royalty and
the variants that are here where the
number of expected variance actually
goes above the number of
variants those are biochemically
non-neutral now physiologically
nonviolent so they're selected away by
the evolution but what it's super
interesting to us here is them as the
variants that are biochemically
nonmutual and physiologically waters
that mean or the peels revolution these
are the variances will save us when the
disease comes because we have a bunch of
variants which are sitting there which
are making us all different but at the
same time healthy so some conclusions
helping people carry a lot of functional
baggage at least efficient as many as
25% of business and health individuals
are non-neutral collection is restrained
from removing many functionally non
neutral variants so common variants of
healthy individual respectfully function
and may accept it as much or more than
rare one and really interesting we
weblab fails to identify functioning
significant theories we don't always
have to trust your experimental
biologist friends and very importantly
followed morphisms could contribute to
disease in a pathway model disease so
not by themself so the most important
conclusions in positions of those is
that evolution is reflected and
conservation is not the only defining
factor very rare variation does not
people to disease and the knowledgeable
the functional significant countless
variation does not mean that is the
variance of neutral functional and
stressful significance is not equal to
disease structural significance is not
equal to functional significance this is
the one that most people have a problem
with and more importantly most current
methods are not independent and let's
give you the same result so you can't
use the logical too much of gave me the
same connection so it must be true and
of course you should know what exactly
you're predicting so to sum it up the
many individual specific variants create
the genetic background that is necessary
to break this camel's back but there is
no last strawberry that's not that one
straw that breaks the camel's back so
it's just this background
altogether but give you the
predisposition so that's it for my talk
this could be people that this
the work this guy max Miller is the one
that is responsible for the real sad
story this is the people that gave us
money and thank you and I'm looking for
both that we're a fun round thank you so
much for that informative presentation
cell robbers we want to begin our Q&A
segment this is a reminder of how
audience members can communicate with
that questions can be submitted via the
Q&A button at the lower left it were fun
able to get to your questions due to
time constraints dr. Bart will be
capturing some any questions via email
so let's start with a bunch of questions
on dr. Bacher audience member would like
to know what is the one major obstacle
getting to a really good variant effect
predictor that is an excellent question
I think there's a major obstacle here is
really getting experimentalist to give
us data to do the analysis of the base
of experimental data in depth to follow
up on all the varies to do into the
commuter Genesis across entire stanzas
courteous and very well identified
individual variance effects preferably
done in one lab using the same
technology using the same people in
Holland so forth so I understand this is
complicated but I think the biggest
problem of very implementation is really
the lack of experimental data the
ability to use available data is limited
and people don't really share very well
but also the funding for these service
studies where you are not guided by
hypothesis that we need to address but
rather just doing these monotonous
experimental tests if somehow limited
scope really works for mental data
we'll probably solve the problem thank
you thank you so much another great one
we never be able to judge a decision by
simply looking at individual sharing
that's a question that I get asked very
frequently no the answer is no outside
of the Mendelian diseases which we have
actually covered very much at this point
with our experimental techniques there
is no obvious way of judging of the
genetic you know hilarious so you may be
predisposed to a disease but through a
set of environmental factors
remember nature versus nurture you may
or may not develop it so even the most
well associated and popular things to
check for like let's say drakul on
ground the two variants which are
associated with breast cancer what we
see is that having a very crease of your
chances of developing cancer but it
doesn't guarantee that you will get down
and actually the way to look at these
variances so say hey I'm going to follow
up I'm done to both cream for this stuff
I'm going to make sure that my doctor is
aware hopefully the doctors will be
aware it's good enough
now this is something that is possible
that is more likely than what is
expected so you will never be able to
say yes you have this variance you will
get the disease with very few exceptions
but you will be able to say you're very
likely to get this disease please watch
your diet go do some more exercise take
this drug one of those things and as
monitoring of course healthcare
monitoring is really important and I
think that's going to be the biggest
things how do you fit your doctors
monitoring of you on the basis of your
genome I think that's going to help us
prevent diseases rather than 2,000
pounds
maybe Walter longer it's time for one
more question whether it be school for
evolution very may contribute
so as I mentioned the fuel for evolution
variants they are the ones that make us
all different they're the ones that are
responsible for you being different for
me they're the ones that give us this
wonderful diversity of their population
we are very very much similar we have
the same type of genius most of the
success of genius most of our time is
promising so I have to if you don't
there's a disease that's associated with
that but we're also very different why
and these are the variants to talk and
affect the biochemical tests on the
function of the thirteen but they do not
have a diseases like the fitness set and
when I take the old resolution I am
basically saying that you are one one
option for the continuation of our
species the evolution does not place all
eggs in one basket so basically every
single one of us is a collection of
variants which has the potential to be
the most advantageous for a particular
environment we may never figure out what
that environment is but it may be the
most advantageous set so one very good
example of this is this human woman
sickle cell anemia marian's where is
actually still in the population even
though it's positive of sickle cell
anemia because it is also protective of
malaria so in malaria rich regions
persons with the fairies is actually
going to be as advantageous in the
heterozygous form so basically fuel for
evolution is really we want to make sure
the fire of our species keep going no
matter what environment throws at us and
what does that means getting the leaders
of some states have seen the populations
and now long term in a large team of
thing for our species that doesn't
matter as an individual person gets it
what doesn't matter is that the species
goes on and of course for us we want to
be healthy everyone's our friends to be
healthy every one of the world to be
healthy but these variants are going to
be made
since ages but that's the ritual date
for the sake of the continuation of this
issue a doctor's offered for this
important point you don't seem to have
any more questions would you like to
take them only in custom final comments
for the audience
yeah I guess the one thing that came out
for me from this research is that you
have to be really clear about what it is
that you're doing for every kind of
research for every research project you
have to be you have to define very well
in difficult something's but you have to
define very well what would be three
ideal things that you would be looking
at if you took away the constraints that
are experimental in nature or the time
in nature what would you be doing and I
think that a lot of people forget to do
that I think that the reason that we
have so much confusion is because we're
creating this vacuum in which to put our
experiments in them and then we try to
apply our results to the outside world
in December to find quiet fail and I
just would like to remind everybody that
it's important to remember the world
outside
thank you again dr. Robert I'd like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational workshops possible today's
webinar will be available for on-demand
viewing
so obviously 2017 keep an eye out for an
email from Bob rates alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we encourage you to forward dis
announcements your calling we have miss
today's live event for joining us I hope
to see you next time